democrats are making it no secret that
they're searching for a plan b
as president biden stumbles his way into
becoming one of the worst presidents in
american history headline after
headlines show party officials fretting
about joe's old age and plummeting polls
democratic king maker jim clyburn laying
out who he thinks will succeed joe biden
well you know
it's no question in my mind that joe
biden is doing exactly what needs to be
done for this great country of owls
we all know
that our democracy is teetering on edge
we need a joe biden
to get us through this rough patch and i
think he's doing
great with that we know that his podcast
includes uh
vice president harris i support her
and
i'm just saying that if
he
chooses not to run again
first on my list after him would be
kamala harris yep democrats say it's
kamala's time to shine never mind or
disastrous time in office and poor
handling of issues like the border
msnbc's joy reid thinks you just don't
know the real kamala quote
i think she doesn't get to show that
personality often enough and so people
haven't had a chance to get to know her
most of the media is still white and
male
and their take on kamala harris becomes
the take it becomes conventional wisdom
you know what joy is right americans
don't get to see the real common enough
so here's a reminder
i experienced great
joy
when i watch this brilliant
phenomenal
black woman
jurist
be so smart
just cut through
the political gamesmanship
that they were attempting to
incite
dana when she speaks
so
slowly is she trying to think of things
to say or is she trying to sound
very thoughtful perhaps a combination of
both right because sometimes the
sentences don't quite make as much sense
as that one did i mean you could
understand where she was going it wasn't
as much of the word salad that we have
seen before interestingly about the
articles that we've seen since the new
york times first broke the seal saying
that joe biden shouldn't run again in
2024
is that
there's never any of the democrats
quoted sins are not like but we have
comm lester everything's going to be
fine
there's none of that except for
congressman clyburn who i think is being
uh
the statesman and he's trying to be kind
but there's that is not happening and
evidence of that is that they had to
cancel a fundraiser because not enough
people wanted to pay fifteen thousand
dollars for a photo with kamala harris
and now there's a california event in
its place only charging five thousand
dollars so if you're trending down on
the fundraising leading into the midterm
it's hard to imagine that that goes back
up in 2024 how much do people pay for a
picture with you uh they pay well
15 grand but they get more than a
picture jess
more like a video
they pay with their life for hours you
know the thing is when you showed that
video of her somebody had talked to her
and said you got to start picking your
words
more wisely because she used she uses
words the way like a used car salesman
uses cologne splashes it all over the
place hoping that masks the stench of
incompetence or dishonesty it's exciting
and nerve-wracking to watch her speak
though i've i enjoyed it it's like why
remember the flying willendez it's like
watching a flying up trying to cross a
tightrope between two buildings so you
never know if she's gonna make it to the
other end oftentimes she doesn't i also
like it when people say you know the
real reason people don't like you is
they just don't know you
no it's the reverse it's because they
know you there's a gut instinct that
kind of like from people get they figure
it out it's like what they used to say
about hillary like oh if you you know
people who know hillary oh she's a
barrel of laughs yeah until she kills
you
allegedly allegedly uh we talk about you
know there's a we always talk about um
having a deep bench it's a baseball term
dana got it but uh the dams don't have a
deep bench they have barely a squatty
potty
and it's all full of crap i think one of
those very good really
like long road trips when we would go
from denver to wyoming it was a little
pink one this is an interesting
development that i didn't expect
what do you think about clyburn just not
shutting down the kamala talk all he has
to say is i support joe biden is doing a
great job that's it well here's the
thing about clyburn i mean he's the guy
who gave us joe biden okay so given what
we've had for the last year and a half
i'm really not inclined to go with him
yeah he's going to go with his
recommendation but you know i love the
the the best part of this is is i was
going to talk about fifteen thousand
five thousand most of us at the table
could get that much that the five you'd
probably get fifteen greg thank you yeah
that's because of the video but but but
i love when joey reed said the reason
that that uh people don't know kamala or
don't like her is because they don't
know her well like here here's a tip i
don't want to get to know her i really
don't what i see is enough i want her to
be a leader i want to admire her i want
to make sure that that she's someone
who's effective i want little girls to
look up to her and say i want to be a
vice president like that i don't need
another girlfriend i really don't need
to get to know her i want her to be
effective and by the way
the fact that no one wants to get to
know her better and they won't even show
up for some of these fundraisers she's a
total disaster and 64 of americans don't
want biden to run again i mean that's a
huge number that is a huge number and i
can't imagine that last number i heard
of her was 28 approved of her so i doubt
she's going anywhere and i don't know
why they continue with this with this
this charade oh yeah he's doing what's
right and she is too they're not we're
in a mess she might be a hidden gem
though oh we'll talk about that later my
segment more on that later so joy says
she's getting a bad rap because the
media is mostly male and mostly white
what about dick cheney was he covered
fairly by the mainstream media same
white male media didn't treat him very
well
but paul's controlled that way
i think that um i listened to
congressman clyburn carefully and i
think everyone's right there was not a
there's not a burst of we are fully
behind and we can't wait for joe biden
to run again i do think that it's hard
for me to imagine the president not
seeking re-election
um the some democrats are concerned
about his age and i read a story
yesterday that this ageism stuff i don't
really engage in but i think democrats
need to stop worrying so much about the
mental and physical acuity of the
president what we need to be focused on
is the policy acuity
if policies were working to the extent
that some around the table would agree
with and for that matter
the polling data suggests that a lot of
the country wants things to be different
we wouldn't mind a few stumble over
words or even a stumble up the stairs i
think the country is ready for
a stronger set of policies on the border
on crime inflation now for republicans
launching never-ending attacks is not
going to win the race next in two years
you've got to lay out a positive
narrative and vision for the country if
you're able to do that i don't care what
party and you're able to defeat an
incumbent president but you're not going
to defeat any president by just saying
he's bad he's terrible he's old at least
there are a number of people who've lost
races doing it the guy named mundell who
lost to reagan saying he was he was too
too old of a guy so
look i think there's no no question
democrats and biden have to get better
if they don't get better uh
republicans are going to be able to not
only launch a serious campaign but maybe
a winning campaign in two years maybe a
winning campaign wouldn't that be
something it would be something but you
know what uh you know there is a point
to be maybe it's time for younger people
to be in office yeah you know somebody
like me yeah
you know what i support ageism
in that case i'm not tall enough but you
are not definitely not tall enough but
you do have a quick wit that'll get you
halfway there hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else